Democrats not battling each other over
gun control beta or creating a divide
with some in his party after
emphatically saying he wants to take
away assault weapons but mayor Pete Buda
jag agreeing that O'Rourke's comments
give the right-wing ammunition to attack
democrats Buda jack also saying this
right now we have an amazing moment on
our hands we have agreement among the
american people for not just universal
background checks but we have a majority
in favor of red flag laws high-capacity
magazines banning the new sale of
assault weapons when even this president
and even Mitch McConnell are at least
pretending to be open to reforms we know
that we have a moment on our hands Beta
Phi ring back at Buda jig for saying
President Trump and Mitch McConnell the
Senate Majority Leader may be interested
in gun reform tweeting in part quote
bleep that is not enough neither is pol
testing your message gun violence is a
life or death issue
Dayna to my ears it sounds like they
both agree they want fewer guns on the
street and they want fewer murders with
guns
but how do you hear it well okay but one
of them said that we that the government
would literally go and take people's
guns from them like a mandatory buyback
basically means no we're taking them
from you that is not like the mandatory
part is what I think got everyone's
result raised right it's not like an
assault weapons but I think we all know
where better work is going right like
they don't define it and I think mayor
Pete is saying you better are pushing us
so far to the left that we can't
possibly think about winning in 2020
all right so Jesse the question is I you
know like over the weekend I was in
church at the ballgame Democrats love
this great talk you know the NRA is
always winning the argument cuz they say
extreme you know you're going to come
take our guns Democrats did he says it
and then Democrats are pleased to hear a
Democrat stand up and speak not in
political terms but directly to the
issue so is this a messaging fight or is
there something bigger I don't know what
kind of people you went to the ball game
with but I don't think people are very
happy about it even Buddha judge and
he's right about this the Democrats have
always wanted to take your guns it's a
beta as this one stupid enough to say it
you guys have always wanted to chip away
at the Second Amendment and bado came
along with a chainsaw
and said let's go and you guys usually
win elections when you're moderate not
when you act like Mad Men there's no
chance now legislatively you're gonna
get anything done when someone like bado
comes out and says this and now
gun-toting Americans don't trust
Democrats so they didn't trust them on
guns very much to begin with if you look
at all of the issues the Democrats are
running on global warming taxes guns
immigration they've lost their patience
and they don't want incremental change
anymore they want to just go full-bore
open borders socialism raise taxes grab
your guns and that's scary stuff bado is
a man-child he I honestly believe he you
know was seriously and genuinely
affected by the mass shooting but now
he's shrunk his kandacy down to a single
issue that will never grow up into
anything nationally and he's been you
know wrong on this issue from the very
beginning because if you look at I have
a list of all the latest mass shootings
here in the last I think six years
ninety to eighty-five percent of them
all pass background checks and the ones
that didn't the kids stole the gun from
his mom or dad so it's really not about
the rifle which is legal it's about
something other than what they're
talking about
all right so but Greg I think you have a
situation where Americans are very
concerned about mass murders and people
being shot actually okay so I think that
this is a big issue I thought from an
other perspective than Jesse's you could
say bado
is now talking in harsh extreme terms
about assault weapons in the way the NRA
speaks and he is forcing President Trump
and Democrats to do something in the
middle he validated everything the NRA
had said would happen and he's done more
damage for real change when it comes to
limiting access of guns to the unstable
that anybody ever could as somebody who
I can I can no longer trust the Khan
red flags is somebody who basically
introduced it here come two to three
years ago bado showed me how the red
flag gimmick would be callously abuse
and targeting people that he doesn't
like what if he finds that he thinks
that you are too pro-gun he could report
you which is what he might do because
that's the kind of bureaucrat he is he
says he'll yes he's gonna take your guns
no I predict he'll be taking my order at
Starbucks and in El Paso outlet he bade
his quest it's purely egocentric
he's got no talent he's got no wisdom no
persuasive skills he's the guy who has a
Jack Kerouac novel and that's back of
his pocket that he doesn't read he's got
an acoustic guitar that he never knows
how to play but has it out in front he
is the candidate version of Phoebe from
friends
every time she showed up on in an
episode of Friends you just were like
waiting for her to get off screen he is
Phoebe from friendly cats but the public
in terms of just with the post-show say
public likes red flag laws likes
background checks even higher cap on
magazines and assault weapons and
Republicans and NRA members say yes to
all those measures what you are citing
is the majority of the public being open
to legislation moving for that makes
sense that reflects a common sense okay
Vado came out with a confiscation plan
that will not work legally or
politically or socially or for assault
with basically just to reiterate that
point sure for his over what does that
mean all that means a rifle right for
his over-inclusive definition of assault
weapons so to me it's not about opening
the right wing to attack it's about
radical versus reasonable and I don't
think the NRA is reasonable 36% of the
NAR AR Democrats and so if you're owners
are in the NRA what they are yeah I
don't think most NRA members like
background checks red flags or they are
reasonable we have them
I don't know about that good um I don't
know I forgot where I was going so no
it's okay but I just so Timmy mayor Pete
is wasting his time he is punching down
by engaging with Beto's kind of
inflammatory rhetoric that at this
moment is working for him but his star
is waning his meaning Vado's so I think
absolutely if the Democratic Party wants
to have the Republicans seem like the
reasonable ones then go ahead and keep
talking about confiscating weapons but
right now whatever the amount of time
we're spending on that is what that is
doing